[Música]
precisamente para continuar ahondando en
lo que supone la muerte este lunes de
Silvio berlusconi el que fue tres veces
Primer Ministro de Italia y Magnate de
la comunicación al frente de mediaset
contamos ahora con el politólogo Nicolás
fuste Nicolás Muchísimas gracias por
estar con nosotros en France 24 para
analizar esta noticia de última hora
Marta Moya nuestra compañera nos
acompaña también en el estudio Nicolás
el empiezo preguntando por un poco la
cuestión que ahora sobrevuela la
política italiana y es Qué pasará con
Force Italia la formación a política
liderada por berlusconi que forma parte
de la coalición de gobierno de liderado
por la por Georgia meloni por la líder
de extrema derecha pero que sin embargo
giraba en torno a la personificación de
berlusconi
bueno Muchas gracias por la invitación
para comentar esta noticia
sí Exacto es una porcentaria del partido
es un partido que forma parte de la
coalición de gobierno
yo no creo que haya muchos cambios desde
el punto de vista político
Antonio tayán y es el canciller italiano
es un exponente de porcelalia muy
cercano de hace muchos años y es una de
las figuras más importantes de este de
este gobierno Por ende yo no creo que
haya cambios políticos importantes por
lo menos en el breve periodo no
por lo menos hasta las elecciones
europeas que van a tener lugar dentro de
prácticamente un año no creo que esto
Insisto que haya diferentes grandes
cambios en en porte Italia comenzó
siendo digamos el el partido principal
de la centro derecha italiana en este
momento es el socio Junior diríamos No
ese socio minoritario de la coalición
conformada por tres partidos de Italia
Georgia meloni la lega de salvini y
fuerza Italia Pero insisto no creo que
al menos en el breve periodo y me
animaría a decir tampoco en el en el
mediano plazo esto vaya a traer a traer
grandes cambios en en el gobierno el
apoyo del gobierno Hola Nicolás Buenos
días yo le quería preguntar Bueno aparte
de que fuerza Italia está muy ligado a
Silvio berlusconi está muy personificado
no en su figura leía un artículo que
decía que no se sabía si fuerza Italia
podría sobrevivir a un partido sin su
figura Esto bueno habrá que ver con el
paso de los meses como se reconfiguran
esas fuerzas al interno del partido pero
también en la coalición de gobierno no
porque al final sí es un socio Junior
pero es una figura muy arraigada de la
política italiana y me gustaría
preguntarle cómo queda esa
reconfiguración de el espectro político
italiano con la pérdida de una figura
clave en la historia de la política en
las últimas décadas
Bueno sí decíamos escribió parte de la
historia italiana es sin duda la figura
de la Segunda República para los ponis
urge luego del escándalo de manipulita
no a principios de los de los años 90 de
Gran escándalo que termina digamos con
los partidos o con el sistema de
partidos en Italia verduzconi entra como
un tren en ese en ese en la escena
política italiana de los años 90 hasta
este momento fue una figura hasta el día
de su muerte fue una figura
extremadamente importante porque yo dije
que que fuerza Italia es un partido
Junior pero es un partido es clave para
para el gobierno sin fuerza italiano
este gobierno no podría no podría no
podría trabajar no Entonces se dijo que
averluzconi era un pequeño Trump no yo
creo que es un poco más que un pequeño
atrape es un antecesor de Trump no
Exactamente
no es una es la una versión
norteamericana o estadounidense de de
berlusconi peroluzconi no solamente
cambió la política italiana cambió la
televisión en ita televisión en Italia
es extremadamente importante con verlos
con y la televisión cambió no estoy
diciendo que cambió ni para mejor ni
para peor digo Sencillamente que cambió
el deporte ustedes nombraron que
brusconi no solamente es es bueno era
simpatizante del del Milan sino que fue
el dueño de Milán durante mucho tiempo
entonces cómo queda reconfigurada la y
lo último Perdón un tema sobre lo que
ustedes acaban de poner luz en la
pregunta veo Marta que nombraste es que
fuerza Italia fue el primero de los
partidos modernos personalistas no
Entonces es muy interesante la pregunta
yo no sé si tengo una respuesta una
respuesta muy concreta Pero qué va a
pasar qué pasa con un partido
personalista porque por sitalia es
berlusconi no cuando su cuando su su
líder natural fallece Bueno vamos a ver
que vamos a ver qué es lo que pasa
es que no tenemos no tenemos mucho
tiempo y rápidamente para acercar a la
audiencia de América Latina que no
conozca la figura de berlusconi le pido
rápidamente Por qué se dice como usted
mencionaba que cambió la televisión y
que cambió la política en hechos
particulares
era el dueño de mediaset mediaset era
una de las cadenas más importantes de
de televisión audiovisual no solamente
en Italia usted también menciona en el
caso de España y también en otros países
entonces verlos Pony cuando gluconi
llega al gobierno Él sigue el gobierno
como dueño de prácticamente mitad de la
televisión italiana privada pero a la
vez como jefe del gobierno y como jefe
del gobierno tenía la última palabra en
la televisión pública entonces a través
de los top shows de la televisión como
decir
no demasiado profunda de los programas
con no con público que aplaude
constantemente
con chicas jóvenes esta manera de hacer
televisión es una manera de hacer
televisión que nace o que llega a Italia
con berlusconi programas televisivos que
realmente
la figura de los cony aparecía bastante
bastante nombrada bastante evocada
iberlusconi también de esta manera gana
un gran consenso en
en los en las en los sectores más
la parte de la población no más anciana
no entonces
de esta manera hacer televisión de
barlujones y realmente reformula la la
televisión la televisión y la bueno la
radio la televisión y todo el mundo
audiovisual en masivo y Nicolás o sea
Hablamos de que Silvio berlusconia
marcado una parte de la historia
política en Italia pero también su
figura está directamente relacionada con
numerosos escándalos tanto en su vida
pública como en su vida privada Cuál ha
sido el peso de estos escándalos al
interno de Italia pero también fuera de
las fronteras italianas
recordamos el escándalo
Ángela Merkel no llamándolo de una
manera que yo no voy a repetir no pero
haciendo alusión al físico de markle o
también cuando berlusconi para liberar a
una joven cercana a perluzconi en verlos
Connie por teléfono a una comisaría y
dijo que esa joven era la sobrina de mu
Barack no el líder de de Egipto bueno
Esto seguramente fueron decisiones de
glucón y que no no ayudaron a Italia en
el plano internacional
entonces bueno si estos estos
escándalos como decir forman parte como
decía antes de las grandes de las
grandes contradicciones de berlusconi y
bueno lo colocan también como como líder
líder populista digamos no pero bastante
bastante anterior a tranvia el populismo
que vemos hoy no una especie de
antecesor Sí pues Nicolás
Lamentablemente se nos acaba el tiempo
para continuar abordando la figura de
berlusconi pero muchísimas gracias por
habernos acercado aquí en France 24 yo
no se alcanzaría todo el día para hablar
exactamente
Muchísimas gracias también por
acompañarnos en esta entrevista gracias
Y ustedes sigan con nosotros que
enseguida volvemos
[Música]